welcome to this video yeah this is the
final video of the of the offbeat
opening section so what do we get what
is offbeat Bishop c4 maybe something
like that in pretoria and she's got this
amazing long text here been one lip
Adichie yeah so maybe them the beginner
okay it's taking them mm-hmm that is
some right I really don't know that
completely on my own him there is this
real what is this quarter Frankenstein
Dracula variation wow that is a move Wow
okay um Saudi for you
I'm just playing and playing a bit
quicker here than usual not thinking for
too long this success is up d6d six what
did you play clean with chrome e90 of
three is also interesting g6
well
it's not exactly my kind of positioner
complete chaos but it's a nice clean air
695 is an interesting point okay here
well let's just take let's just take and
go back I guess 495
it looks good passer but I want the
night to go 25 which I managed now
it takes on c3 actually I mean I wanted
to get the night to differ okay now I
place completely different but the funny
position no idea what's going on here 95
maybe i'm also on the e5 pawn let's do
that
the bishop is 3 or a 4 a force may be
better probably should be three and
there's also see three now as a possible
okay so Queen age 69 f5
Bishop e3 oh wow what a demon
so let's do this I have Queen f6 here
castles bishop age six is very
problematic i yes discoveries by another
this night no he doesn't so what is this
then
just one moment damn ok I have to play
that I cannot wait now it's the only the
only move Bishop e6 and then he's
playing night age 6
ok so i have to take I guess shop g7 is
on taking there's no option ok let's
take him a Bab I'm attacking a look
why do I go actually that's a important
question don't have square what a great
idea okay let's go here now we can
actually take on b5 but I'm remaining
with a decent position and to be one to
stay actor there mm-hmm how do i get my
one-minute time morning okay eight at
the end he's quite tight tight down
there okay idea hmm
very likely i missed some stuff that
already and I g5 is just now I don't
believe that move one bit probably
there's some real reputation
winning yet another pawn so might win
this my king is not playing which is bad
news but okay let's get the King up it's
important King up to d3 here like f 3g
for h1 that's not good let's go for a
Troy I wonder person can also try to win
win another pawn down here threatening
f4 just being a little bit annoying
check no not that was exact that wasn't
good technical play
it was bad just played that badly would
have had it much much easier it's not
even clear to me if I'm winning now
Kingdom kingi to maybe look at four ah
look at four okay okay yeah I know I
don't have much time but still it was
relatively easy oops check check check
check check check mate wow I already
played that terribly when I was winning
but poor little stuff okay so let's have
a look at that opening i really i really
wonder if if the snatch five is is
somehow refutable immediately I mean d4d
for looks right here but just taking is
probably good young jam maybe this is a
simple simple and good yeah just take
this gathered is that something for the
opening review of that week cam okay I
can take here jack Queenie seven is kind
of kind of lame I did want to want to
try to refute what he did there was some
cute lines yeah I'm for example as I
looked at this like here
here and nights is Chang this this
whoops whoops check and make is the line
that I saw during the game but he
doesn't have to him after this Chad can
play this myth and it's it's like
completely insane I took play dance and
yeah I don't know what that is because
I've he forms g6 Bishop takes is 64
strong starting with this move okay here
yeah it's not not quite clear where he's
going just that just wins just wins yeah
I can't ejaculate here win the group
that was much better than yeah i was i
was thinking here and i only now saw 95
that really keeps things together and I
should take only sexy Anna here FTX
something like that I really don't know
what this is he has a point for the
exchange and two bishops and it's a
completely weird position there's always
this trickier with this this double
attack damn and well I had blundered
into this but it wasn't so easy it
wasn't so easy pre hit somewhere around
here he must have made a mistake I don't
know what it was here before now it gets
it gets kind of tricky and after that
I'm better I'm really better
we should be five covering that is
better job very very difficult to play
yeah this is endgame is a very easy win
but I totally i miss played it quite a
bit look aged six is better and so on I
got very nervous I don't know really why
but um ok so I have to close I have to
have to end this video now need to need
to run somewhere ok guys thanks for
watching and make sure to watch the
opening review of this week the offbeat
section thanks for watching